الدافع الوحيده لهذه الخطوه هو الحفاظ على
الوطن في مواجهه التدهور المستمر للحاله
الامنيه في بلادنا
بعد اعلانه تشكيل مجلس انتقالي برئاسته
قائد الانقلاب في النيجر يحذر من اي تدخل
عسكري اجنبي ويعلن عن تعليق العمل
بالدستور وحل المؤسسات وباريس تقول انها
لا تعترف سوى ببازوم رئيسا في حين قال
متحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
للجزيره ان الاستيلاء غير الدستوريه على
السلطه بالنيجر يعرض التعاون الامنيه
للخطر الشديد
انفجاران نتيجه سقوط صواريخ على مناطق
جنوبيه شرقيه روسيا وفي اوكرانيا كيف تقول
ان القوات الروسيه شنت نحو 30 غاره على
اراضيها وعقد مباحثاته في كييف رئيس
الوزراء وزير الخارجيه القطري يدعو لابقاء
كل قنوات الاتصال مفتوحه لحل الازمه ويعلن
عن تقديم بلاده مساعدات انسانيه قيمتها
100 مليون دولار لاوكرانيا
الامم المتحده تقول ان شهر يوليو والجاري
في طريقه لان يكون اكثر الشهور سخونه في
تاريخ البشريه حيث من المتوقع يكون متوسط
درجه الحراره العالميه اعلى بمقدار 0.2
درجه مئويه على الاقل من يوليو 2019 وهو
اعلى معدل حراره مسجل سابقا وفقا لبيانات
الاتحاد الاوروبي
نادي الاهلي السعوديه يعلن رسميا ضمه
الدولي الجزائري رياض محرز قادما من
مانشستر سيتي حتى 2027 بعد خمسه مواسم
قضاها في النادي الانجليزي الذي نشر بيانا
اكد فيه انتقال محرز واورد فيه مسيرته مع
الفريق والانجازات الشخصيه والالقاب التي
حققها
الى اللقاء